bonjour à toutes et à tous je travaille
sur une technologie qui est considéré
par certains gens comme ridicules
dangereuses ou même évidente sur les
interfaces cerveau ordinateur
les interfaces qui permet de capturer
l'activité électrique du cerveau d'une
personne pour contrôler n'importe quel
objet pas la pensée oui c'est bien ça
pour contrôler n'importe quel objet pas
la pensée c'est comment être un peu
angélique semaine d'ailleurs il ya un
dernier qui vient de sortir il ya pas si
longtemps
bah voilà c'est la même chose par contre
il faut que je vous dise la vérité on
peut pas aujourd'hui et lire dans les
pensées
ça ça c'est l'exemple ziba vous dit non
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
comment sa fonction il faut manger on le
met des casques sur la tête une personne
et après on demande à une personne
d'imaginer quelque chose par exemple en
mouvement sans effectuer ou une
visualisation d'un objet et léhady
casque médicale on utilise la recherche
il y à des casques grand public et alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce que vous détectez par exemple
vous êtes stressé
vous êtes au boulot en train de
réfléchir sur un problème votre
responsable a déjà envoyé quatre mètres
de suite pour un projet dont la dead
line était hier soir et vous en train de
travailler sur ce projet on peut
détecter si vous êtes stressé
si vous êtes anxieux si vous êtes
dépressives ou même si vous venez
commettre un suicide
aussi votre enfant ce soir voilà vous
avez passé cette soirée avec des
docteurs
il est trop content on entre là on va
dire maman mais au fait est ce que je
peux rester le lundi soir chez pol on va
finir en projet là c'est pour l'école
bon québécois déjà en au moins deux
vigiles mais c'est pas grave
là par contre pu essayer détectée est ce
qui est en train de mentir
cette information est dans le cerveau
pendant 72 heures
attention ça s'utilise mais d'une
manière légale uniquement aux états unis
dans quatre étant ici en france ça c'est
pas possible
mais si vous allez éviter aux états unis
là vous pouvez l'utiliser sur votre
enfant de manière tout à fait légale ou
pas exemple d'un train de remplir un
questionnaire ou choix multiples vous
avez coché une case à une question 2 et
vous êtes contents parce que vous pensez
que ça c'est une bonne réponse vous
allez passer une question suivante en
question trois ou un train de fléchir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça en réponse à
une question 3 et là vous vous rendez
compte que la réponse correcte
un question de s'était pas à mais
c'était bon est ce que ça vous arrive et
je pense assez souvent
bâle a justement le cerveau génère un
signal qui est très particulier qui
relève d'une erreur ou tout à l'heure
vous avez fait une pause il y avait un
accueil café
j'imagine c'est trop bien moi j'ai pas
pu profiter parce que je tamponne deux
filles
il répète et maintenant je vais bien
justement avoir un café au lait bana ok
phrase normal vous comprenez tous bien
ce que je veux bon elle a pas venu
s'encastrer riquet pour un espérons
qu'elle va tenir jusqu'au fond de 18
minutes
mais si je vais vous dire je vais du
café au chat 400 millions plus tard dans
l'iss à vous de vous tous il y à des
activités qui va apparaître qui
s'appelle m400 parce que c'est une
réponse négative 1 qui va paraître 400
millisecondes plus tard et pas parce
qu'il ya parce que je viens de dire est
pas correct ça n'existe pas des cafés
aux chats aux chiens aux choses et les
fonds
alors qu'a fait au niveau mais le but
ultime de cette technologie est de
détecter quand on imagine quelque chose
de manière volontaire c'est à dire si on
imagine justement des actions des
mouvements par exemple voilà une
expérience que j'ai fait en 2013 2014 à
bord notent quand j'étais encore en test
la paire son contrôle seront uniquement
par la force de sa pensée il faut et il
fallait imaginer en nuage pour le
décoller parce que ça relève du sial là
il faut que l'imaginent au monde de la
main gauche pour que le drone passe pour
qu'il tourne à gauche
là il faut imaginer un moment de la main
droite pour que le groupe puisse
continuer à tourner sans effectuer le
mouvement toujours et après pour les
tenir il faut imaginer une pelouse parce
que ça relève 7 heures la version bouge
pas et de fait tout ça en imaginant
juste par la force de la pensée
vous allez dire ok c'est bien c'est un
drop a three city et si bon ok ça peut
être rigolo dès le seuil est contrôlée
comme ça mais si on veut faire par
exemple pas je peux imaginer un mur un
jeu imaginé un oiseau ou un sac à main
bah oui vous pouvez imaginer tout ce que
vous voulez il n'y a pas de limite
une fois vous allez décider qu'est ce
que vous voulez imaginez pour que après
l'autre on vous écoute pour que le
système puisse exécuter des actions
il n'est pas de souci si vous voulez
vous pourriez imaginer lamborghini votre
vélo
tout ce que vous voulez ok bon bah il ya
des drones c'est très bien mais ça reste
quand même
des applications un peu limité mais ça
va fonctionner avec n'importe quel autre
robot si c'est un robot qui roule
pourquoi par exemple des machines pour
faire la vaisselle pourquoi pas
attention je dis bien des machines qui
font l'aller c est pas mon chéri est ce
que tu peux faire la vaisselle s'il te
plaît sur votre chéri savait atteint
après j'essaie avec les millions que
coûte et y voit la cabine et elle est
même pas au courant que j'essayais mais
bon ça va pas fonctionner sur les gens
voilà il fallait tout vendu texto mots
il n'était pas toujours d'accord ok bon
des robots c'est bien d'être 11
serrières rigolo mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire un plouf on a quand même des
télécommandes on a quand même des des
smartphones qui contrôle tout ça on a
des ordinateurs c'est bien ici une deux
fois mais pour quoi faire
parce que il faut le faire à cause du
pôle est bonne c'est un garçon très
gentil qui vit dans une maison et pour
le en lit comme nous tous à la maison en
une table quelques livres des chaises
mais le lit du pôle est automatisé ils
détournent nos pôles deux fois pendant
les nuits aux horaires préprogrammés
parce que paul il peut pas se détourner
tout seul ou psy paul veut manger
ils ont un système qui lui est de faire
pour ne peut pas choisir lui-même est ce
qu il veut d'abord manger son pain et
après prendre sa bouteille de soda non
c'est le système qui décide pour paul et
quelle vitesse il a mangé c'est aussi un
système a décidé il ya eu tant moyens
c'est ça ce que le système utilise et si
qu'ils t'ont offre à paulhan boucan bas
pourquoi physique qu'on lit tous dans le
métro dans le train roule en un système
qui va lui tourner des pages une pages
par minute
est ce que paul il peut pas ni bouger ni
parler ni même pas vraiment clignoter
des yeux il faut mettre de la solution
dans ses yeux pour que ça ne se sache
pas parce que paul et person à la
mobilité dite mais paul a un enfant qui
fonctionne toujours
ce sont sarah souvent restent toujours
fonctionnel il comprend très bien
qu'est ce qui se passe autour de lui
alors ces systèmes sont utilisés ils
sont développés pour les gens comme paul
c'est sûr ça ce que je travaille sur les
systèmes qui peut changer les qualités
de vie de paul et de gens comme paul ok
on a une technologie qui a l'air
chouette parce que ça t'a vont changer
la vie des gens
on a même une application ou un peu
voilà un peu ludique
voici d'ailleurs une expérience que j'ai
fait un grenoble toujours en 2015 quand
j'étais encore un thèse une contrôle
d'une maison à la pensée où les gens
imaginaient une porte pour vivre porte
imaginez une ampoule pour allumer la
lumière
imaginez un délit vous l'allumez ou
imaginaires des volets pour les faire
baisser
ou pour les faire remonter j'ai testé ce
système avec des paires son camp paul
aussi des personnes en bonne santé
tout le monde a aimé mais alors c'est
quoi le problème de ce système pourquoi
alors tout à l'air bien toute dernière
fonctionner oui à part il ya un petit
défaut il y a un pied des filles dans
les interfaces
il nécessite l'entraînement on peut pas
juste mettre un casque sur la tête d'une
person et dire à quoi elle pense ça
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui
même si tout d'abord on va mettre un
système sur moi qui devais le système et
que sais tu comment sa fonction et après
on va mettre ce n'importe qui dans cette
salle ça va pas fonctionner il faut
qu'on entraîne le système pour
reconnaître vos pensées c'est à dire il
faut que vous imaginiez pendant quelque
temps des actions que vous voulez que le
système puisse se reconnaître
pour que les utiliser dans vos
applications pour paul il fallait deux
mois pour qu'ils imaginent une action
d'allumer détendre pour arrêter le de
tonneaux monde du son lit du mois et
c'est pas juste deux mois ces deux mois
chaque jour l'enterrement de deux à
trois heures pour lui un autre système
que vous venez de voir leurs tables du
pilotage du devront leur salut au moins
pour qui le système de bien fonctionner
en moins une heure par jour pour
entraîner le système à connaître quatre
à six commandes du contrôle de drones
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec c'est ce
qu'on peut améliorer ce est-ce qu'on
peut le rendre plus facile plus
raisonnablement ce délai oui parce qu'il
ya un truc qui était dans le cerveau il
ya toutes les différences le cerveau est
fonctionnel et opérationnel tout le
temps 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
n'est pas fonctionné dans un seul cas si
la personne est morte à part les autres
cas sa fonction même s'il prétend qu'on
comprend pas et c'est tout ce que je dis
c'est nul
non on comprend très bien ça peut être
juste de ne pas être intéressant alors
et la propriété très très connu je pense
vous allez vous connaître quand je vais
faire quelques exemples exemple je vais
vous dire fantastique
génial super c'est mieux ce que je veux
dans ma vie yakuza n'importe quel autre
question mais pour tes questions est ce
que vous trouvez maroc est ce que vous
allez me repose je peux vous dire pour
vous vous allez me donner une réponse
positive est bien plus que ça vous allez
utiliser les mêmes mots que je viens
d'utiliser moi même si mon pote
forcément penser que c'est trop belle
jolie
j'espère bien cuit comment vous allez
utiliser c'est moi parce que je viens de
prononcer votre cerveau a été primée
amorçait vous donner une réponse
positive ou un autre exemple en train de
regarder un film et vous allez voir une
bouteille du soda dans un film après
vous un store vous allez au supermarché
et vous allez acheter une bouteille de
soda c'est ça ce qu'on appelle
l'amorçage parce que vous venez de voir
cette image pendant quelque temps dans
un film vous déprimez pour acheter cette
bouteille de soda on a de développer
l'expérience dans un jeu du tir où il
fallait imaginer une impôts torche pour
avoir le contrôle du jeu tout d'abord
j'ai fait en système dont sa fonction
sous les gens d'une manière explicite du
leurre bien dit il faut que vous
imaginiez l'importance pour la voir
c'est à dire que je fais les interfaces
cerveau ordinateur classique mais les
mêmes notre coupe des gens dont je leur
laisser faire d'une manière notre
naturel le rien dit qu'il faut imaginer
quelque chose il faut pincer lampe
torche
il a juste commencé en jeu et le quai
sans aucune instruction de ma part après
aux demandes au bout d'un moment ils
sont retrouvés là dans un couloir où il
fait sombre
naturellement vous pouvez pas continuer
à bouger il faut que vous avez de la
lumière
et là d'un seul coup jean vous donnez
une impudeur ch
je vais enregistrer les simu
vos signaux électriques en même temps
après vous allez retrouver vos mères
quelques années plus tard du nouveau
dans un couloir
il fait sombre à quoi vous allez repensé
vous avez besoin de la lumière
vous avez toujours besoin de la lumière
ou sept bisons si vous allez repenser un
an potache
vous avez la mort sans aucune indication
du système qu'il faut imaginer il faut
penser à ça non c'est parce que c'est
naturel parce que vous pensez à ça parce
que vous avez envie ou même pas envie
besoin de sa nécessité
sa venue le temps d'entremont et ça peut
rendre les systèmes exploitables en
manque cinq minutes pour avoir trois à
quatre commandes on considère que le
cerveau c'est un organe qui est qui et
quand même pas parce que on oublie les
numéros de téléphone de nos amis on
oublie date de son anniversaire
mais on oublie qu est ce qu ont vaqué
cependant miladin homogène dans tout à
l'heure il ya deux jours on oublie ça il
faut consulter des agendas mais en fait
ça c'est pas vrai votre cerveau c'est un
système de calcul le plus pieds sont qui
existent dans le monde
c'est plus puissant qu alpha kovats
n'importe quel autre système qui a
essayé de battre un an dans un jeu et
cette force c'est déjà en vous merci